ha sido en canadá de padres chilenos y
de origen mapuche a cabo y quiero
compartir el orgullo de su identidad
su nuevo sencillo latino soy es para
este artista un himno sobre el orgullo
de tener orígenes latinoamericanos
latinos hoy habla de esa convicción de
pertenecer a una comunidad que abraza a
sus antepasados y también de lo que une
a los habitantes del continente de habla
hispana la historia la cultura la comida
los valores la relación con la tierra y
la naturaleza justamente que estamos en
el mes latinoamericana la herencia muy
importante darle su debido lugar hay
muchos latinos radicado en canadá
compartiendo y ofreciendo la cultura
porque sea por por sea por por la comida
por la el arte por el idioma por las
costumbres y entregando algo muy
y ancestral que conociendo conocimiento
ancestrales a la cultura canadiense
también es cierto
así que no olvidarse que el latino tiene
toda su raíz
antes de todo indígena de méxico para
abajo porque si no fuésemos españoles
eso es lo que tenemos en común y una
belleza la verdad cuando uno sale desde
su país de origen y está aquí en canadá
empezamos empezamos a ver los latinos y
empezamos identificando como latinos acá
wii también reflexiona sobre lo que es
identidad latinoamericana representa
cuando uno vive lejos del territorio de
dónde viene su cultura y tiene un
mensaje para los jóvenes latinos de
canadá yo tuve la suerte de que me que
mi madre mi padre siempre me demostraran
y culturas idiomas de libre y bendecido
de eso porque ahora tengo la posibilidad
de hacer carreras musicales en español
diciendo que yo nací aquí pero siempre
pero alguna
a temprana edad conocí la tierra de mi
papá y fue que me sentí muy identificado
sigo sin entiendo me ha identificado
latino 100% más con mi descendencia
mapuche y es de eso a las nuevas
generaciones de latinos como yo que
están creciendo que van acker que nacen
acá es de no olvidar a los padres que
demostraré la raíz de mostrarle su
idioma porque si no si no sabemos de
dónde venimos no sabremos jugar para
dónde vamos y para qué porque estamos
luchando en el hus también más encima en
los momentos en los tiempos que estamos
viviendo para seguir adelante y con una
buena educación
para este proyecto el músico invitó al
rapero mapuche luanco minuto soler que
presenta un rap en mapudungún la lengua
mapuche y a los bailarines peruanos de
semilla cruz de villamaría todo ello
acompañado de ritmos urbanos y mestizos
latinos hoy fue escrita por acá we y
arreglada por hedayat miren esa me deje
diet música en francia el videoclip fue
dirigido por cristian navarro de en cola
audiovisual quien se encargó de la
dirección edición y postproducción a
distancia desde la araucanía paloma
martínez para radio canadá
y que vivo a la raza